[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
crise afflux trafic noyer misère menace
échec de l'intégration à quoi ces mots
vous font-ils penser
aux migrations et si l'émigration
pouvait être envisagée de façon positive
moi quand je pense aux migrations je
pense d'abord aux femmes aux hommes et
aux enfants que sont les migrants et si
je pouvais si je devais les résumer je
retiendrai 5mo 3 leur appartiennent et 2
désigne le contexte auquel ils sont
confrontés les trois qui leur
appartienne sont les mots courage
semblables et libertés
le contexte est fait de blocages et de
violences le mot courage mais c'est à
l'évidence le leur
ce sont des héroïnes des héros de nos
sociétés contemporaines
ils osent remettre leur vie en jeu pour
trouver un horizon ou tout simplement
pour survivre
c'est rare et remarquable semblables
mais parce qu'ils sont comme vous comme
moi ils ont des aspirations des rêves
des envies des besoins et ils veulent
leur part du gâteau
mais n'ayez pas peur ils ne veulent pas
une part de votre gâteau ils veulent
simplement pouvoir concocté aussi le
leur avoir accès aux ingrédients pouvoir
se réaliser et enfin liberté parce que
aucun d'entre eux ne veut quitter pour
toujours
ils veulent être libres d'aller et de
revenir
ils ne veulent pas quitter pour le reste
de leur vie ils cherchent une liberté
d'aller et de venir des allers et des
retours
mais le système auquel ils sont
confrontés
et là j'en viens aux deux autres mots
c'est un système de blocage
les migrants sont bloqués dans leur pays
d'origine ces sites
difficile d'en sortir ils sont bloqués
dans les pays de transit
bien souvent aux mains de mafia et enfin
ils sont bloqués quand bien même ils y
arrivent dans le pays de destination
dans des situations administratives et
socio économique extrêmement précaire et
de la le dernier mot la violence
ces murs et frontières ces barrières
c'est extrêmement violent cela fait 25
ans voyais 25 ans que comme avocat du
rencontre des migrants des centaines de
trajectoire des centaines d'histoires
individuelles de parcours singulier des
jeunes femmes qui cherchent la liberté
des hommes qui cherchent un horizon des
pères et des mères un avenir pour leurs
enfants par exemple
abdoulaye abdoulaye est un jeune
nigérien il en veut il suit une
formation en informatique donné par une
ong dans sa petite ville mais boko haram
et dans la région il ya beaucoup
d'insécurité et du coup pas de travail
mais tout le village voit qu abdoulaye
il a suivi une formation il connaît les
blancs ceux des ong et donc le village
se cotise et donne pour mission
abdoulaye de partir en europe d'aller au
nord pour leur prodiguer des ressources
qu'ils n'ont pas et abdoulaye accepte et
ne croyait pas que c'est facile ne
croyez pas qu'il se dit où jouent et
c'est moi non non c'est dur c'est très
très dur
il laisse sa mère ses petits frères
petite soeur il laisse une femme qu'il
aime et il doit prendre son petit sac
son petit baluchon et comment cela la
traversée du sahara hyper des compagnons
arrivé en libye il est séquestré
quelques mois sa famille et racketter
vient ensuite la traversée des rives de
la méditerranée
il y a des morts des bateaux qui se
renverse et ils arrivent ils arrivent en
europe
c'est déjà un homme abîmé mais
déterminés qui arrive déterminer
pourquoi mais il a un projet pour lui
mais il a un projet pour tous les autres
derrière qui attendent et que
trouve-t-il l'illégalité
il se rend bien compte très vite qu'il
n'est pas le bienvenu mais il fait des
petits boulots mais son projet personnel
très difficile de le réaliser
quant aux projets pour les autres le
projet collectif c'est encore plus
compliqué même s'il envoie le peu qu'il
a alors évidemment on pourrait dire à
doulaye m'écoute nous sommes désolés on
n'avait pas demandé de venir et tu es
illégal il vaut mieux rentrer mais
rentrée imaginez-vous mais c'est
impossible avec pour seul bagage un
échec les mains vides
et en plus le risque de devoir refaire
ce parcours dantesque d abdoulaye j'en
ai rencontré des centaines ils sont des
milliers au fond de la méditerranée
d'autres milliers réduits en esclavage
en libye et puis des milliers ici
surtout dans le sud de l'europe
accueillir des tomates pour 2 euros de
l'heure pour que nous puissions les
acheter pour 1 euro le kilo au printemps
si des voies légales avait existé
d'où là il les aurait emprunté
il aurait préféré ne pas devoir
traverser cet enfer il les aurait
utilisés pour venir en europe mais aussi
pour rentrer et de la cette idée de la
migration circulaire ma vision c'est
celle de permettre abdoulaye et aux
autres de circuler d'aller et de venir
la circulation est alors accepté en ce
qu'elle est naturelle et inéluctable
mais elle est aussi organisée organisé
parce qu'on incite abdoulaye à aller
voir le consulat un guichet migratoire
plutôt que le passeur ou le trafic en
mai des propositions existent
depuis des années des spécialistes
propose de supprimer par exemple visa
court séjour mais d'être exigeants sur
la transformation du court séjour en
établissement ou alors d'offrir des
visas à entrées multiples un visa à
entrées multiples qui permettrait chaque
année de venir quelques mois si
abdoulaye trouve un travail la première
année bien très bien il reste s'il n'en
trouve pas il doit repartir mais il peut
revenir légalement plus tard peut-être
avec les contacts qu'il a nouée
cette proposition était une utopie
moi je pense que l'utopie au contraire
c'est de croire que l'on va arrêter avec
des barrières ce que l'être humain a
toujours fait alors pourquoi défendre
avec urgence ce nouveau paradigme vient
d'abord parce que il est révoltant mais
je suis révoltée de voir cette jeunesse
abîmé en méditerranée s'en remettre aux
mains des passeurs également parce que
la mobilité augmente avec la
mondialisation tout circule les biens
les idées les images nos images de ce
soir là elles vont très vite circulé
elle circule peut-être déjà maintenant
sauf une large partie de la population
et certainement aussi parce que
peut-être plus égoïstement égoïstement
de mon point de vue des européennes il
est plus enthousiasmants de faire ce
pari de la mobilité que d'organiser la
multiplication de mur de plus en plus
aux deux plus en plus longs de plus en
plus cher et de plus en plus meurtrier
alors évidemment la migration ce sont
des questions complexes il faut
réfléchir rationnellement et se
documenter sur les flux la nature de ces
flux cela représente
qui quoi combien ce qui augmente depuis
plusieurs décennies et va continuer à
augmenter ce sont les flux sud nord et
c'est en lien avec la démographie
alors ayons à l'horizon 2100 le
continent africain formera 35% de la
population mondiale tandis que nous les
européens allons passer de douze ennemis
% à -2 7% et pour des raisons
historiques linguistiques et évidemment
géographique l'europe est le principal
continent de destination des migrants
africains
il y a donc bien là un défi et pour
faire face à ce défi lieu au modèle
actuel et celui du blocage est utilisé
plusieurs fois le mot blocage et même
celui de la forteresse
on parle d'europe forteresse l'arsenal
juridique européen est principalement
concentré sur le contrôle de la
forteresse des frontières et son
renforcement et la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale
soit mais par contre il existe très peu
de voix légale d'accès que ce soit pour
un court séjour ou un long séjour
mis à part les plus nantis ou les
hautement qualifiés il est quasiment
impossible d'obtenir un visa par exemple
à des fins exploratoire si abdoulaye
avaient voulu obtenir un visa il ne
l'aurait jamais obtenue est donc cet
arsenal juridique est en total décalage
avec la réalité des flux les flux sont
majoritairement formé en partie des
migrants forcés les demandeurs d'asile
pour qu'il n'existe pas non plus de
voies légales ou très peu mais la
majeure partie des flux sont formés de
travailleurs faiblement ou moyennement
qualifiés et quoi qu'en disent nos états
il y a du travail pour eux j'ai cité
tout à l'heure les tomates
l'horticulture mais aussi tout le
secteur du soin aux personnes
il est assurée principalement par des
femmes migrantes
mais les conditions de travail de tous
ces migrants sont effroyables quand ils
ne sont pas en séjour illégal ils sont
bien souvent en séjour précaires et les
conséquences de cela sont dramatiques en
termes de précarisation d'exploitation
et d'intégration on parle d'échec de
l'intégration mais quelle intégration
quand on se trouve dans une telle
situation
alors évidemment la forteresse me direz
vous peut-être c'est un choix politique
et même démocratique
on a voté pour cette forteresse mais
elle a largement montré ses limites
la forteresse elle encourage quoi les
passeurs les mafias mais certainement
pas abdoulaye à aller voir le consulat
pour exposer son projet son projet en
outre au-delà des questions éthiques et
elles sont fondamentales liées aux
déséquilibres de la mondialisation et au
partage des richesses la forteresse
elle est totalement inefficace les murs
à ce qu'on tourne ça se passe ça se
renverse mais à quel prix
le coût humain est effroyable des
milliers de morts chaque année en
méditerranée et dans le désert sans
parler en plus du coût matériel de la
construction frénétique de nouvelles
barrières
alors évidemment plutôt que de permettre
aux migrants de circuler plus facilement
comme je le défends on pourrait lutter
contre les inégalités
mais évidemment qu'il faut lutter contre
les inégalités
mais ne nous y trompons pas lutter
contre les inégalités ne va pas limiter
l'émigration les plus pauvres ne circule
pas les plus riches il voyage les plus
riches
la classe moyenne elle circule et plus
il y a deux classes moyennes plus il ya
d'aspiration à circuler mais cette
circulation gagne alors en qualité ce
n'est plus une circulation forcé de
survie
une circulation volontaire et croyez moi
la circulation volontaire elle est
circulaire avec une envie de retour et
elle est vertueuse aussi parce que celui
qui circulent il transporte avec lui ses
ressources ses envies ses idées
quelle richesse alors politiquement
qui va oser qui oserait défendre un tel
nouveau paradigme en fait ce ne serait
pas une révolution c'est la base de
l'union européenne la libre circulation
et donc on l'a fait et lorsque l'on a
fait tomber les barrières au niveau
européen lorsqu'on a supprimé les
frontières y at il eu un débordement des
pays qui ont été envahis mais pas du
tout tout au plus une circulation qui
s'adapte à la conjoncture aux
conjonctures elle-même évolutive lorsque
l'irlande a connu un boom économique et
à de travailleurs polonais sont allés en
irlande
lorsqu il y a eu une crise en irlande
bien ils sont repartis avec une
expérience dans leurs bagages
l'être humain est rationnel il va là où
quelque chose l'attend cette rationalité
et elle l'apanage des migrations
nord-nord mais pas du tout on observe
exactement le même phénomène entre
l'angola et le portugal depuis qu'il y a
une grosse croissance économique en
angola des travailleurs européens et
notamment portugais se déplace vers
l'angola
elle enfin peut-être un dernier point
sur lequel s'arrêter nos peurs les peurs
d'une partie de la population européenne
je pense d'abord que ces peurs elles
sont liées au décalage entre le discours
l'immigration doit être jugulée arrêté
et la réalité il y a de l'immigration ce
qui donne en permanence l'impression que
les migrants ce sont des intrus et puis
aussi au mode de gestion utilisé en
matière migratoire avec un ton qui est
toujours ambitieux gêne au possible des
sommets européens
on décide pendant la nuit en dernière
minute comme face à une épidémie se
narratif négatif fait peur fait peur et
il crée aussi des fantasmes les italiens
lorsqu'on les interroge dans les
sondages disent qu'il ya 30% de migrants
en italie
or y en a moins de 7% il faut donc être
attentif à ce narratif négatif qui est
responsable de ces peurs parce qu'à côté
de cela les voyants sont au vert
l'immigration est bonne pour l'économie
il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir peur des
migrants rien ne démontre qu'il pose des
problèmes de sécurité
il reste la délicate question des
valeurs de la perte de repères de la
mixité de la culture mais regardez
autour de vous la mixité
elle est déjà là nous la vivons au
quotidien
regardez les images des jeunes qui
manifestent dans les villes de belgique
et ceux qui manifestent un peu partout
dans le monde
la migration et la mixité de la culture
ils la vivent
je crois fermement que si on modifie le
narratif que l'on développe un narratif
positif on se rendra compte que la
circulation accepté choisi emmène avec
elle de belle énergie et qu'on pourra
enfin laisser tomber ce sinistre mot de
crise pour envisager l'immigration comme
une liberté une rencontre et des
synergies
je remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]